Some of you have heard the story before,...
...but in fact, there's somebody in the audience who's never heard this story in front of an audience, before,...
...so I'm a little more nervous than I normally am telling this story.
I used to be a photographer for many years.
In 1978, I was working for Time magazine, and I was given a three - day assignment to photograph Amerasian children,...
...children who had been fathered by American GIs all over Southeast Asia, and then abandoned.
40,000 children all over Asia.
I had never heard the word "Amerasian" before.
I spent a few days photographing children in different countries...
...and like a lot of photographers and a lot of journalists, I always hope that when my pictures were published,...
...they might actually have an effect on a situation instead of just documenting it.
So, I was so disturbed by what I saw and I was so unhappy with the article that ran afterwards...
...that I decided I would take six months off.
I was 28 years old.
I decided I would find six children in different countries and actually go spend some time with the kids...
...and try to tell their story a little bit better than I thought I had done for Time magazine.
In the course of doing the story, I was looking for children who hadn't been photographed before,...
...and the Pearl Buck Foundation told me that they worked with a lot of Americans who were donating money...
...to help some of these kids.
And a man told me, who ran the Pearl Buck Foundation in Korea,...
...that there was a young girl who was 11 years old, being raised by her grandmother.
And the grandmother had never let any Westerners ever see her.
Every time any Westerners came to the village, she hid the girl.
And of course, I was immediately intrigued.
I saw photographs of her and I thought, "I wanted to go." and...
...the guy just told me, "There's no way. This grandmother won't even"...
..."you know, there's no way she's ever going to let you meet this girl that's she's raising."
I took a translator with me and went to this village found the grandmother, sat down with her.
And to my astonishment, she agreed to let me photograph her granddaughter.
And I was paying for this myself, so I asked the translator if it would be okay if I stayed for the week.
I had a sleeping bag.
The family had a small shed on the side of the house,...
...so I said, "Could I sleep in my sleeping bag in the evenings?"
And I just told the little girl, whose name was Hyun Sook Lee, that if I ever did anything to embarrass her,...
...she didn't speak a word of English although she looked very American,...
...she could just put up her hand and say, "Stop."
And I would stop taking pictures.
And then my translator left.
So there I was, I couldn't speak a word of Korean...
...and this is the first night I met Hyun Sook.